Welcome back.
Let's do some more
derivative problems.
Let's say I want to figure out
the derivative d over dx of--
and let me give something that
looks a little bit different--
x to the third minus 5x to the
fifth, all of that to the third
power over 2x plus 5
to the fifth power.
This is a parentheses.
This is just saying that I want
to take the derivative of
this entire expression.
So you're saying Sal, we've
never learn how to do this,
you have something in the
numerator, you have something
in the denominator I don't
know what to do next.
Well let's just rewrite this.
Actually in your calculus
textbooks there's something
called the quotient rule, which
I think is mildly lame, because
the quotient rule is just the
product rule where you have a
negative exponent and they make
it another rule, and they
clutter your brain.
So instead of using the
quotient rule, we're just
going to rewrite this bottom
expression as a product,
and then we can use
the product rule.
So this is the same thing as
taking the derivative of x to
the third minus 5x to the
fifth, all of that to the third
power, times 2x plus 5 to what?
The minus fifth power.
And now we can use
the product rule.
Take the derivative of the
first term-- and the derivative
of the first term isn't a
joke-- you take the derivative
of the inside first, let's do
the chain rule, derivative
of the inside first.
That is 3x squared minus 25x to
the fourth times the derivative
of the outside, 3 times this
entire expression x to the
third minus 5x to the fifth.
And then all of that, take this
exponent down one to the
squared, and then multiply
it times this whole term.
So 2x plus 5 to
the minus fifth.
And then to that we
add the derivative of
this term, so plus.
So the derivative of this term
we take the derivative of the
inside, which is pretty easy.
It's just 2 times the
derivative of the outside,
which is minus 5.
And just so you know I didn't
skip a step, the derivative of
2x plus 5, the derivative of 2x
is 2, derivative of 5 is 0.
So the derivative of
2x plus 5 is just 2.
So it's 2 times
minus 5 2x plus 5.
We just keep that the same to
the minus fifth power, and then
we multiply it times this first
expression, x to the third
minus 5x to the fifth
to the third power.
I know that's really messy and
you'll probably not see
problems this messy, but I just
wanted to show you that the
product rule we learned-- it's
actually the product and the
chain rule-- they can apply to
a lot of different problems,
and even though you hadn't seen
something like this where you
had numerator and a
denominator, you can easily
rewrite what you had in
the denominator as a
negative exponent.
And then of course it's just
the product for when you don't
have to memorize that silly
thing called the quotient rule.
So with that out of the way,
I'm now going to introduce you
to some common derivatives
of other functions.
And these things are actually
normally included in the inside
cover of your calculus book,
and they're just good to
know, good things to know.
And maybe in a later
presentation I'll actually
prove these things.
You should never take
things at face value.
So you should to some degree
memorize these, although you
should prove it to
yourself first.
So the derivative of e to the
x-- and I find this to be
amazing. e shows up all sorts
of crazy places in mathematics,
and it's you know the strange
number 2.7 whatever, whatever
and it has all sorts of
strange properties.
And I think this is one of the
most bizarre properties of e.
The derivative of e to the x.
So if I want to figure out
the slope of any point along
the curve e to the x-- this
just might blow your mind.
I think the more you think
about it, the more it'll blow
your mind-- is e to the x.
That's amazing.
At any point along the curve
e to the x, the slope of
that point is e to the x.
Just to hit the point home.
I'm diverging, a little bit.
But if I said f of x is
equal to e to the x, right?
And let's say f of 2 is
equal to e squared.
And I asked you, friend-- I
don't know your name-- what
is the slope of e to the x
at the point 2,e squared.
And you could say Sal,
the slope at that
point is e squared.
That blows my mind that it's a
function where the slope at
any point on that line is
equal to the function.
And it's e. e shows up
all sorts of places.
I might do a whole series of
presentations called the
magic of e, because e shows
up all over the place.
Well I don't want to diverge
too much, so that's
pretty amazing.
Next I'm going to show you what
I think is probably the second
most amazing derivative-- and I
don't think this has been fully
explored in mathematics yet,
because this also blows my
mind-- is that the derivative
of the natural log of x, right.
So the natural log is just the
logarithm with base e, and I
hope you remember
your logarithms.
So what's the derivative
of the natural log of x?
So once again this
is e related.
Well it's 1/x.
That also blows my mind.
Because think about it.
Let's draw a bunch
of functions.
If I said the derivative
of x to the minus 3 is
minus 3x to the minus 4.
The derivative of x to
the minus 2 is minus
2x to the minus 3.
The derivative of x to
the minus 1 is minus
1 x to the minus 2.
The derivative of x to the 0--
well this is just 1, right?
The derivative of x to the 0 is
just 1, so the derivative is 0.
The derivative of x is 1,
derivative of x squared
is 2x and so on, right?
So it's interesting.
We have this pattern from all
the derivatives of all of the
of kind of the exponents in
increasing order where you go
from x to the minus 4 x to the
minus 3, x to the minus 2 and
then there's no x to
the minus 1 here.
We go straight to x to the 0.
What happened to x the minus 1?
What happened to this?
What function's derivative
is x to the minus 1?
This is bizarre to me.
Where did it go?
And it turns out that
it's a natural log.
This I still think about before
I go to bed sometimes because
it is kind of mind blowing.
And later in another
presentation I might
actually prove this to you.
But just to know that this is
true, that the derivative of
the natural log of x is 1/x
I think is mind blowing.
And so for now you can
just memorize it.
But both of these
are mind blowing.
The derivative of e to the x is
e to the x, and the derivative
of the natural log of x is 1/x.
And I'll just do a couple of
more just to present them to
you, and then in the next
presentation we'll actually use
them using the product rule and
the chain rule and et
cetera, et cetera.
And you might want to rewatch
this and memorize them.
I want to clear image.
OK.
And now I'll just do the basic
trig functions, and you should
memorize these as well.
The derivative of sin of x--
this is pretty easy to
remember-- is cosine of x.
So the slope at any point
along the [? line ?]
sin of x is actually the
cosine of that point.
That's also interesting.
One day I'm going to do this
holographically because I
think that might not be
sinking in properly.
The derivative of cosine
of x is minus sin of x.
There are good to memorize
though, because you'll be
able to recall is quickly
on a test and then use it.
And then finally the derivative
of tan of x is equal to 1 over
cosine square of x which you
could also write as the
secant squared of x.
You might want to memorize
these now, and actually I
encourage you to explore these
things, I encourage you to
graph each of these functions.
Graph a function, graph its
derivative and look at them,
and really intuitively
understand why the derivative
function actually does
describe the slope of
the original function.
And actually I'll probably
do a presentation on that.
But I'm almost out of time
in this presentation,
so just memorize these.
And memorize the derivative of
e to the x, e to the x, and
the natural log of x is 1/x.
And in the next presentation
we're going to start mixing and
matching all of these
functions, and we can use the
product and chain rule on them
to solve kind of arbitrarily
complex derivatives.
Between what we've just seen,
we could probably solve 95% of
the derivative problems
you'll see on say the
calculus AP test.
I'll see you in the
next presentation.